[Music]
as we reflect on the one-year
anniversary of the pandemic we're taking
a moment to honor the more than
538 thousand people in the u.s
who have died for the past year we've
shared the stories of the remarkable
people we've lost some were known to the
world others only to loved ones
but all made a significant difference
here are just some
of the many lives to remember
[Music]
[Applause]
antoine hodge was an opera singer known
for his powerful base baritone
and his kind commanding presence
[Music]
he would always find light and love for
every person
and everything said his friend arthur
boyton
originally from georgia antoine
performed with professional companies
across the country
before moving to new york city and in
2019
he achieved a dream joining the ensemble
for the metropolitan opera's revival
of porgy and beths
[Music]
antoine was ecstatic to have finally
made his met debut
and for more doors to open boital said
he was waiting in the wings for his
moment
antoine hodge was 38.
martin and madeline schwartz were
married for 65 years
they grew up in brooklyn just two blocks
apart
but had never met in the early 1950s
when marty was stationed with the air
force in san antonio
and madeleine was vacationing with
family they finally met at a military
ball
marty and madeline fell in love said i
do
and built a large family before retiring
down in florida
marty was an avid golfer madeleine loved
to travel
they sent their grandkids custom-made
birthday cards in the mail
every year in february marty and
madeline got
vaccinated but days later were admitted
to the hospital
where both tested positive for covet 19.
they died four days apart
martin schwartz was 90. madeleine
schwartz
was 87.
claudette white was a tribal judge who
fiercely advocated for the quasan
tribe in southern california
okay she was featured in the 2017
documentary tribal justice
for her work as a chief judge in tribal
court
focusing more on healing families and
resolving conflicts through mediation
instead of punishment through
incarceration tribal court about lots of
times is about people
claudette was the first in her family to
go to college
and at 23 years old became one of the
youngest members elected to the quetzan
council she helped her tribe stop the
building of a nuclear waste facility
in the mojave desert land they consider
sacred
claudette had a tattoo of a native
american wonder woman
on her arm she cared for her people and
loved her people
like a superhero would her son zion said
she was a strong person even in the face
of death
she wasn't scared claudette white
was 49.
[Music]
petty officer second class cody myers
was an information systems technician
in the u.s navy cody was passionate
about seattle sports
theater jazz music and lord of the rings
a natural-born leader he was always
helping friends
through tough times he was one of the
greatest men i've ever known
said his longtime friend isaac monroe in
february
after cody's last trip out with the navy
he was awarded an
achievement medal for his work on the
georgia-based ballistic missile
submarine
cody loved his country but most of all
his family
he and his wife mallory were raising
their first child together
cody died a few weeks before his son
asher's
first birthday i'm thankful
mallory said i feel like we lived 100
lives
in seven years cody myers
was 26. cody's family is hoping to hold
a memorial for him at t-mobile park
where his beloved seattle mariners
played
another footnote here the metropolitan
opera this fall will dedicate their
opening night performance
of porgy and best antoine hodge i love
that this is the thing about your pieces
anthony it shows there's no rhyme or
reason many times it affects
all colors all ages all genders and it
just doesn't make sense
so many cases discriminate in any way
shape or form really doesn't
all extraordinary lives in their own way
and all deeply loved
we'll be right back